as for uh the sec nick saban set to join
us here
and uh is coach with us ready to go okay
uh coach thanks for joining us you know
we were talking about before you came on
that i think you were at michigan state
for four years when tom brady was at
michigan for four years what do you
remember about tom brady
at michigan uh
that that's interesting because my last
year at michigan state
tom brady was a senior and they had a
guy named drew henson who
was you know supposed to be a really
really good quarterback and a first
round draft pick in baseball and
they couldn't they couldn't settle on
who should be the quarterback
so we actually beat them 34 to 31
um and uh i think they scored 31 points
when brady was playing quarterback
and they didn't score any when drew
henson was playing
uh so that's what i remember
and and henson was this two sports star
and
we didn't really know what brady was and
then brady gets drafted by
belichick and the patriots he's behind
drew bledsoe and then
you go to miami and then you end up
facing brady a couple of times after
that what do you remember about that
well we we were actually um
two and two against the patriots
in the two years that i was you know at
miami
uh but you know the patriots were always
you know sort of the toughest opponent
in terms of
they had good players but they were
really well coached they had
really good system and um
you know if tom brady was really on his
game
you you really were in for a a difficult
day
so um that's kind of what i remember
and he he's been a good player for a
long long time and
certainly a great ambassador for the
sport what quarterback kept you up at
night considering all the great
quarterbacks you faced
you know college or pro
well i i think when i was a defensive
coordinator
at the cleveland browns for double check
you know you had john elway dan marino
that that whole crew you know that came
into the league and uh
in 84 or whenever it was yeah and um
they all when your defensive coordinator
you know you just really start
you worry about stopping stopping the
other team so
i have lots of sleepless nights over
those guys
yeah i think elway is might be the most
talented quarterback i ever saw in the
nfl because
he had that strong arm he was he could
run a two sports star
you know it was just when he lost super
bowls then all of a sudden you can't be
the greatest of all time
when you're losing three super bowls
they put all that blame on him but
um i i still wonder what elway would be
like in today's nfl
well i think it'd be i i
he was the most difficult guy to defend
and you you mentioned the reasons why
you know the other guys were all
talented passers
and very very good at that part of the
game but
when you try to defend someone and their
dual threat
they have arm talent they can throw the
ball they can't beat you throwing
but then they can take off running
scramble extend plays
that creates tremendous problems for you
on on defense and that's what john elway
did that the others didn't do um
whether he won or lost super bowls or
not if you're the defensive coordinator
and you're playing them you're not
too concerned about that part you're
just concerned about trying to keep your
job
uh we're talking is somebody cutting you
off there coach
yeah oh yeah i just had to
auburn fan uh no i don't think so
we're talking to uh nick saban the
alabama head coach and you're still
scheduled to open up uh at missouri on
the 26th of september
you you feel 100 confident that's going
to happen
well i think that the mindset with the
players for a long time has been
you know they're practicing they're
trying to get prepared for a season
really with a lot of unknowns not
knowing
exactly what was going to happen and
so you almost felt like you were
sacrificing
your time for the season but i think now
you know everybody has really looked at
it a little different you have a
schedule you have a first game
now we're back to investing our time in
trying to create value for our team for
the individuals on our team
to create value for themselves and get
ready to play football and i think
that's the only way that we can look at
it and
really almost have to stop thinking
about well this might happen that might
happen
those things may or may not happen no
one really knows
but at least we have a defined challenge
now that we can look forward to
and that's the mindset that i'm really
trying to get our players to
take because the uncertainty that we've
had
ever since march has created a little
different mindset for everyone
in terms of yeah we're doing all this
work but
what's it leading up to and now at least
we have direction
so um our organization is trying to get
the mindset that we
you know utilize everything that we can
do every day we're actually practicing
now to
uh try to take advantage of of creating
value and investing in a future
does it feel a little more normal if if
you can apply that word to what's going
on now with practice
absolutely um a lot more and
even though we're not really having fall
camp we're
sort of doing the 20-hour week which is
okay
we still have 25 practices and um
so we're we're excited about the
opportunity
and i think the players are as well
what was it like being around you at
home when you couldn't do anything
football wise
well i was one of the few people i think
there was three people in our building
that could come to work so the first day
that they said
you should come home you should stay
home i had a little zoom
set up you know upstairs in my little
office and
um obviously the reason that we were
supposed to stay home is you're supposed
to stay away from people
so when miss terry's crew came
to work about 17 strong cleaning ladies
two yard guys you know accountants that
come and
do her books and run knicks kids
i said i'm safe for going to work
and i'm staying here so
and the one good thing that came from
all this is i never had an email address
so people used to send her emails for me
and like the first day of the pandemic
she got like 500 emails
and she said you're done i'm not taking
any more of your emails so
if you want if if you want your
information
get your own email so i i actually have
an email now
i really mean wow look at you
technological progress
[Laughter]
here you are approaching 69 years of age
i think
in october and you you finally got an
email coach email
address that is great yeah
no matter how old you are you can still
improve
uh did you hear the story when your
former running back josh jacobs was on
our show last year
uh i don't think so that's where he said
that uh
let me play it for you this is what josh
jacobs had to say
uh save is just like he likes to do a
lot of like
these nuts jokes it's funny because like
you i haven't heard one of them since
like
middle school and then saving when i
went to college they used to do it a lot
wait wait wait wait wait give me one
here
all right so one day i was catching i
caught like five passes
um in a row and he was like he's like
hey josh
if you want to hold all boss uh hold
these i said wait
so i just sat there i sat there for a
second i was like
did he really definitely wait wait wait
he was doing dee's nuts to you
yeah i was like coach i ain't heard
uh tua confirmed that story there coach
would you like to comment on these nuts
well um i like to have fun with the
players
i think it's probably good too that they
see you every now and then a little bit
different light
um since i'm a defensive coach and i
probably get on the defensive players
a little bit more ferociously
it's a little easier for me to be
light-hearted with the offensive players
and you know there's some guys on your
team you just love like
josh jacobs to uh you know henry ruggs
you know we've had a lot of really good
players on offense that have great
personalities
and great work ethic and you just love
them and
those are the kind of guys i usually
pick out to do all the teas and stuff
i love it i've we laughed when i've been
i've been doing this a long time coach i
never thought that i would bring up that
topic with you
under any circumstances but then after
josh
brought up your sense of humor and i
said i love hearing that story
so you don't have to apologize or
anything or
you know it was great i got a big
chuckle out of that
yeah at least they remember something
that we tried to teach them
well good luck with the whole process
there coach and uh
we'll be uh we'll be waiting for the
26th when you face missouri
okay dan thank you good luck to you all
right buddy stay safe
talk to you later bye-bye